aux etats unis c'est donc hier que le
documentaire de michael moore est sorti
dans les salles à washington le
réquisitoire contre george bush a fait
salle comble gilles radine avant michael
moore très peu d'américains auraient
acheté un ticket de cinéma pour aller
voir un documentaire grâce à la palme
d'or du festival de cannes
fahrenheit nine eleven est devenu un
film événement à washington en tout cas
dès la toute première séance hier
vendredi à 11 heures du matin
le public était au rendez vous
c'était vraiment génial et j'adore la
façon dont l'enquêté mail c'était très
très très fort vraiment bien ficelé mon
frère est là bas ça fait du bien de voir
un film comme ça je suis ici inquiète
pour mon frère
ils nous ont menti à nous tous ils sont
diaboliques impossible d'entendre la
moindre critique
je voudrais bien que ça change les
choses malheureusement ce qu'ils vont
voir ce film sont déjà convaincu à la
sortie divine surprise pour la deuxième
séance à 14 heures la file d'attenté est
impressionnante
c'est un succès